flash up on Terok on the reengage gets
some of the carries a reckless still
alive but can they keep this game up
it's an impossible offense at this point
rocks and reckless versus the world
reckless goes on a rampage but Ning is
still there pressuring under the turret
with the rest of IG reckless is down
Bronx's away I cheer on Nexus the LPL
has never won before but that will
change today the crownless are finally
king this gaming on your 2018 world
champions the world no call guys the
2018 League of Legends World
Championship was frankly nothing short
of unforgettable I mean you had
defending champions Genji formerly
samsung galaxy going out in groups
you had cloud9 defying the odds and
making it to the semi-finals you had
fnatic making it to the grand final
something no European team has done
since season one and of course LPL took
the crown for the first time ever with
IG lifting the summoner's Cup we're
gonna bring you the best individual
plays the best team plays and the most
emotional out of game moments from this
year's worlds and in less than 24 hours
we're also gonna give you our favorite
fails and funny moments from Worlds 2018
now without further ado guys let's get
on with it with the best individual
plays from this year's worlds oh and uh
sorry one more thing guys we sell sick
t-shirts now if you want to cop this one
or check out the rest of our collection
well we've got a link pinned in the
comment section below to our online
merged apartment along with the video
for kills Jensen is going to be back out
on the field though Andy is Gallio that
might be enough to deter them spence
guards the only damn
left off LeBlanc over the wall Shane's
gonna land back across almost gets that
kill picked up and got in a stopwatch
they're not gonna get the training
they're already deep in the paint and
they chase EDG all the way back here we
go Jackie love is gonna be taken very
low now ignite coming down Jackie having
a flash away to keep himself alive and
Ottilia saunders now in some real danger
foul on pops the ult looking to go
forward yet again calling coming out
rebels trying to absorb the shock their
support dies trying to run did he know
before BCG - setting around the Barons
hips a full presentation is officially
commit on the wonder solid snake is
there there's no jungler we're all eyes
on Wonder but the Baron is just as
important at this stage of the game
wonder now running for his life he
doesn't really have any other options
out wants to pull him back he's gonna
get the fear off can wonder actually
I'll play this he's already to me one
he's already survived he's already
bought enough time for his team to take
the Baron infinity hansika test now or
they're gonna lose everything
Baron dropping for G to wonder is still
alive he's still looking for the outplay
he's gonna break the passive as well
they're gonna try some other one though
this one buddy same stops the queue here
comes Allen as well to v1 proxxon may
have bit off more than he can chew the
health first putting down the kick you
then once again this might buy broccoli
incredible and you can see it stops the
damage of the second QPD Kosak pricey if
I think he surprises the IT jungler and
then just the ability to know that there
is no way out the only way is for Oh
dials on him he could have looked so
silly had he gone down but he makes it
happen and he got a feel so good about
that one client as well
here comes the play X flash through the
wall I say look to make something happen
personal gonna be able to escape one
target that's the knock-up he's gonna
move forward with deed though and keep
an isolated has he been left out put
epochal in with the righteous glory want
some flip perks right back in the team
at is all of a devil would eat once
again saving the day with the table
catch ultimate you've gotta love to use
that interaction there us big enough to
bunch wave again son Jetson I'm gonna
dive back in a snake is able to grab
this knife they bought the cooldown for
vivid and now hazel busting it away but
he's put into the grinder
we stacked up an adult see I didn't know
you could do that Apple fall item he's
gonna have a ton of range on this
Tristana and we'll be looking for
something like Aladeen has to make plays
they know this so they're gonna try to
get let me all right take a look that
beast took a 2008
like this let me may win the 1b two
lambs respite be destroys cuteness that
was beautiful in the one verse at one
you put a great star cats looking for
itself of the Vanga up there but for
that's a solo kill cats does it in style
Sintra wants to take blue buff and clear
with her friends she does nothing in the
won't be one here as you'll see do k
doing a masterful job protecting what
crowd was up to and taking him down it
looks like once again kaboom on the
right page here with the gang
oh what a Dodge on the racial prison
gets the claw dude if we talk about
hundred thieves being [ __ ] when they
kind of neutralize lanes and lose the
minimum but that's gonna be the Kantian
cap we're gonna stall and kill again
makes it look so easy but once again
reckless jumps on top of jakela these
two levels up pinky take up lots of
damage coming out Tristana finds the
solo kill kt rolster pushing all of that
riverside vision the score as well do
with the fancy feet and maybe two ladies
at their 2000 goal deficit and the rest
of EDG there trying to collapse I'm
watching horror can he find look for
sprouting damage hard Scout can just
instigate people nearly eight counties
got like 25 stacks still even mcs with
the Ola and actually ahead inexperienced
at this stage you can see that Proctor
just takes over to that level 5 monster
Ming is optimizing it far all of our god
Jackie laughs and the timing is so key
look at hanabi's teleport about 20
seconds away as the fight started free
man Yuna put all melee champions they
don't want to be too crazy here
execute get set and rides all the way
back to the Frog and that means that I
have seen a style of the Baron is 20
minutes and 17 seconds in walking fnatic
define fnatic they got to look for it
this is their home
their backs are against the walls the
parrot is dropping you've got to stop it
here keeps fnatic hopes alive just when
it is darkest rocks that gets over the
pit he gets the Baron they kill the
Schieffer - eyes gone down rookies into
the middle of for McDowell here comes
the cavalry hig look at the kills double
kill and reckless and fnatic will find
their shop well those individual plays
were sick but obviously League of
Legends is a team game and it's about
what you do with the four other players
on your squad so that said guys let's
take a look at the best team plays from
this year's worlds this organization is
made it to quarterfinals and they are in
Game five with RNG and for the vast
majority of this bulb or so so close the
igniters chicky days the perks is
godlike
and everybody wants to be able to use
that ultimate bit more but they may go
for this now Shroud is down yeah it is
done that Q tank is gonna be good to
state is that look at the only advantage
that me gonna grab some set of birth
blood Baron has expired but it does not
matter ain't gonna jump on the turret
first guy goes in with the elds you
looking to find estimating spell now on
here comes your galley well deep v
redemption is there spam is taken down
get rid of everybody from Katie says
Invictus gaming they claim the face
they'll face they've got this game
we're going back to Baron liquorice over
the top c9 will force them into the pit
and eyes on Jaisal has this flash ex
flash water play first one diamond hit
the target I wanted to get him down Oh
get here as well the rookie comes up
massive for cloud eye and this is what
we didn't get the chance to talk about
its aren t punishing the rotation to the
side of g2 as they find that very can be
higher spam hood alright stand united d
channel does the cost are the vengo
ditch comes out lung
in an adverb stays alive just long
enough for Yankers to get there chain
approach and this time around it starts
to spring on the rng members and yank
Gus's leopard it takes applause turn out
the safety of the forest we can sit out
there willingly us how did you find
who's e Busey why were you face checking
RNG are now running for their lives I
shall who is alone had to bow from what
did buy some time she to a low as well
these two buddy be on a knife's in
London will complete the teleports in
RNG stead depending to the left knee
looks for the regain I shall who is
trucked to the backline wanders looking
for car sir and me is running for his
life left bees down
Norwich er down and Jeju eighths will
never give up and that was all off the
back of beautiful play from Kurtz the
Shen ultimate coming through they're
looking for perks but he's able to
actually dodge out and has employed a
lot of the damage with his cleanse
kiting back to his team is snares of
buying a lot of 5ig just want to
disengage this one quick bow continue to
try to chase bail long gonna be taking
it down about half and here comes the
counter-attack going through now with mo
taking very low jackie love looking to
find the damage has the auto attacks
that's the first kill to fight shy still
looking to find someone else won't give
it away on this time as now it's
it's a double-kill for Jackie's fit
mitch is going to take him down
potentially a plane coming in here from
you tell this is that engage you might
be talking about ring of frost quickly
on nukes Mindy and Ola its Mitty trying
to get the stun on tomate about how he's
locked up and taken down a double kill
Pratap a little bit over aggressive for
this toy from Katie make him pay yep and
that was just the thing of beauty from
bottom over she'll build up on
bloodthirster Laos until it stands still
a little bit more one of Draven's pain
points it's got to know where the axes
are going and now you took on the car so
beautifully stopping the hit on such a
suitcase they get a quick kill during
the fight now at RNG
my thoughts on that
damn clinic right now while walking up
here well let's find out if they can get
the hook that lands onto the shield here
listen gets pulled forward and may lose
his life he flashes away just stay alive
here comes rip Oh Candy's gonna be the
targeted that you always Brooks enjoys
the fight full brain blade flies across
and Brooks epic kill secured now koalas
the target
he gets sent packing in comes empty the
format stack of fanatic is there diving
the tower looking for the third stitch
now is the further follow-up caps needs
to find a room prison that they've lost
one in apply defensive flash caps and
Brooks are trying to run him down
sonic wave
under way cleanup is closed not in range
just yet maker will he go for the place
who actually I'm gonna start it from
Olathe makeover mango finds an old mold
they trying to finish up the Drake
excuse me will get it is finally the
paranoia firm I clean up you want the
customer to flip flashes out of that it
is prevailed but we found one that we
love going down Raider has arrived but
you won't know who's covering the use of
a pit over the phone
my turn a backer operating fees to go in
for a travel with a mastic shuffle
follows into the or horn all they gonna
go down as well and EDT stop now save
that fight and the passive minion wave
is pouring onto the Nexus fanatic bounce
back from their defeat yesterday with
the substitute
oh look another cup does actually fine
double it and it just looks so simple
now the Edward gaming is Ivo
lift the Opie rip and roll a get the two
men connects cow makes it look so sick
that's the ice create a scene I gotta
clear the way they're gonna walk over
the top side please - fifty back door
will easy by for not gonna walk for a
little over whip Oh doctor it down will
it be a fight in goes licorice and it's
a big bunch of damages pops up one but
here comes the backs away
Quadra kill fur cap guardian angels
active on kramer and keen this provides
a tremendous amount of an advantage for
the next team fights fence Karen's is
still on to the down here for cloud nine
they do not want the heart on their boy
boy Oh
- [ __ ] they're gonna find away into the
orange gonna come across and the
knock-up [ __ ] there
5x - 4 0 and the coordinators
this could well be a look at a clean up
the map and the last vestige
brookey had some trouble Hillis off try
to come in and make sure they can find
the kill here one more shot up good
take some down that is a very important
gold for the easier this is one of the
big scaling tidbits but can he get out
it's not him they're worried about it
should be that support the the Vanguard
edge will completely cut them down perks
could be in a lot of trouble now doesn't
have the shroud available try to get
itself away
kama spinning but pvp winning the fight
there's still to catch up on this one
shroud comes back down first i'm gonna
be looking to get himself around this
one trying to outplay buying as much
time as possible
no invasive and big horrible then to
find himself killed
a beautiful stages from g to have the
out plan did you finally find a fight
that goes in that favor those were
incredible plays but they wouldn't mean
half as much without the players behind
them and the storylines that follow them
let's take a look at why this particular
worlds was one of the most memorable and
emotional we've ever seen
lady
[Applause]
beautiful outburst of emotion I've seen
in many years this is when some of the
Japanese commentators saw that nation
focused me qualified yesterday the
lights they have brought to the European
out yes
shocking are Genji
and vitality will take down Genji what a
perfect day for vitality so far a team
with three players who were rupees come
into 2018 they didn't even play in the
LCS went in g1 the world championships
and now they're two syrup on this team
they just knocked them out of worlds 5d3
the push continues fifth on the
attempted kill they're gonna shut down
vitality and qualify for the
quarterfinals if you had told me at the
top of the game cloud9 was getting
through and Jensen was going to be this
dark carry of the team I would have said
you're crazy we had so many people
telling us what we can and cannot do and
that's the background everyone here
comes from this doubt fueled us and I
have so many good memories of working
with all these guys and I want to thank
all my players with all of my heart that
all these memories that we built
together and I know for every single one
of them that this is this is just the
beginning is there just anything else
you would like to say to the fans that
have supported you forever we'll be a
bit rough now but we'll keep supporting
you guys
I think I think it's good to have high
expectations of your the team's that you
want to see succeed like it's not
acceptable that I go to Worlds every
year as the first seed and I [ __ ] the
bed and I just I never performed and my
team never make static groups and yeah I
mean Jesus I didn't think I was gonna
get emotional actually oh that's all
right but like I like it's been eight
years and I can't do this thing but I'm
just I'm never gonna give up so that's
what I want to say they've gotten the
shine in the bottom lane but shy has no
TP this is gonna be your game ending
push one way or the other it's Katie
goes to the base it's gonna be a base
rate Nexus turn number one take it under
half HP Katie look at the end it's right
here right now
big taking down to half its Tigers is
renovated stay inside bottles gonna be
taken very low you count barely gonna be
kept alive scores another 1/4 really
gonna be killed now as well Jeff take a
solo look play
not able to find him Steph go to the
killing spree it's a shy still debate
it's Katie
looking up trying to stand and fight him
they can the shine is made his way on
the inhibitor turret onto the Nexus
turrets they're gonna be taken down
Katie still marching it's a base ray
let's eyes on the blue Nexus Katie's on
thread who's gonna win the shy will not
and Katie thanks again for holy this
should be it big simplifies that kill
and that means the fight continues even
further forward see the baby a good side
to the mouth it slams the spike give it
a big this gaming topped off they're
gonna be just fine really get on anyway
rookies got to change kt rolster I've
fallen and Invictus gaming will do what
has not been done
2014 they will eliminate the three in
first seed and they will move on to the
semi-final Kosovo
[Applause]
the middling should fall baby go Daisy
gate deficits up mechanic keep deliver
the perfect place
I cannot believe that they were able to
do it the food sieve from Europe I'm
gonna fight their way through the plans
after before that even losing in the
quarterfinals of the European LCS
playoffs - now getting through group
stages off the back of a Heimerdinger
and then winning at the very end of the
back of hooks and hit this fantastic g2
squad and it's at Worlds where legends
will fall and new ones will rise up this
could well be a look at a clean up the
map
Korea has been destroyed cloud9 will
make it to the semi-finals three zero
sweep the first time the meme is dead
the gap is closed Korea is not at the
front in fact they are behind the EU LCS
the na LCS and the LPL as they are fully
eliminated from Worlds 2018 people
always come to me and talked about my
Korean bias Korean caster but honestly
the truth of it all as you guys know is
I was always biased towards the best
league of Legends and that was so often
played by the Korean teams they
innovated the meta for so many years but
this year as recently as summer I kept
feeling like we were behind them we were
too slow that the teams around the world
could exploit and this tournament is the
vindication of that belief how do you
feel about that na EU matchup it is
something that the fans dreams are made
of but that may also bring a lot of
stress with it honestly I don't really
care that it's c9 we're going up against
I feel like that's more for the fans but
I'm very happy for the West I feel like
especially towards my European teams I
have a lot of respect I think they they
have all done amazing work this this
world's like especially vitality you who
don't get the same sort of spotlight
that we do since we made it further made
like an amazing run in the group stages
already so I feel kind of proud actually
to be representing the West this time
around which is something that usually
doesn't happen so it's cool that we get
to play or get to see a Western team in
the finals and get to play c9 in the
semis flash up on Zurich on the reengage
gets some of the carries of reckless
still alive but can they keep this game
up it's an impossible offense at this
point rocks and reckless versus the
world
reckless goes on a rampage but Ning is
still there pressuring under the turret
with the rest of my G reckless is down
Bronx a delay I cheer on Nexus the LPL
has never won before but that will
change today the crownless are finally
king and victors gaming on your 2018
world champions see the tears of joy and
rookies eyes the tiny squad here the LPL
squad able to celebrate a famous victory
at Kappa a year of domination for the
LPL the dream of every competitive
league of Legends team C now being
realized as Invictus gaming will hoist
the summoner's caught together and claim
their victory hey Dad the world
[Applause]
crowd behind him so soon Akagi lose
money one day to catch a puzzle
Contador more to another Koko so thank
my teammates oh sure sure
well guys that's all we got for you for
best of worlds 2018 look out for fails
and funny moments flash into the comment
section and leave one and don't forget
to skill-shot the like button I will see
you next time thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]